today on drew
[Music]
you have no idea what's about to happen
it's your birthday oh my gosh
we have a few party tricks up our
sleeves he's the first person that cared
about me
plus the one guest she never saw coming
nice to see a happy birthday it all
starts now
is she gonna be alright
hi um it's my birthday i'm so excited
i love birthdays and
we all thought it would be a really fun
idea if i didn't know
anything that was gonna happen today how
cool is that
this is so exciting i can't believe i'm
here but we can't really do the drew
barrymore
show without drew barrymore can we so
drew come out
we haven't seen each other in more than
a year on text
we were texting all day yesterday and i
was like hey we're just samantha we get
to see each other
all day but i'm so have a seat in your
own show in your own house
i just want to say in the words of
pretty woman if i forget to tell you i
had a really wonderful time tonight
you know what i think you are going to
have a wonderful time you have no idea
what's about to happen right
i don't know but my mouth fell on the
floor that denise is here
dean hi derek are you there i'm free i
am i am
oh he's spinning everything for you the
vffs by the way also have your same
birthday
february 22nd 22 we're having a little
pisces party right here
i just want to say that i am super happy
to be here
and that when we met a few years ago now
i think even before
we had your kids it was love at first
sight and it still is and what i'm
finding out is that
everybody feels that way around you drew
you make everybody feel like their
instant best friend
that's the picture that's the day we met
and i have that in a picture frame in my
dressing room right upstairs
oh i love that okay i hope you have your
party pants on and it seems that you do
and your party flower which i'm in love
with we have surprise
guests check huge giveaways and so much
more coming throughout the show
but first we are going to kick off our
celebration exactly as we should with an
intimate look
at you the one and only drew
drew barrymore this is your life
acting before she could even walk miss
barrymore has since appeared in almost
100 movies
tv shows and miniseries on the other
side of the camera she started her
own production company when she was just
19 years old
and has since produced over a dozen
films including
charlie's angels with a combined box
office earnings over two billion dollars
that's billion
with a b but that's not all for over a
decade she spearheaded an
entrepreneurial empire that includes a
homeline
eyewear hair tools kitchenware and an
award-winning makeup brand
that's flower beauty she's a bright
light in the dark
a breath of fresh air and eternal
optimus and one
wild flower she is drew
barrymore happy birthday drew
this is your life and these are the
people that love you
okay we are ready for our first surprise
guest
and i'm gonna give you some clues okay
let's see how you would do
he would be on your top 10 list of
guests i think you'd want at any party
you once surprised him on his birthday
oh my god and his stupid human trick
david being
one of the greatest television hosts of
all time
do you know who this might be i know
exactly who it is
who is it david letterman let us welcome
david letterman hi dave
everybody hi drew
happy birthday savannah hello how are
you hi
she's dying she can't believe it oh my
gosh
i'm having a great time catching my
breath i can hear you
dave i can't i can't hear her
oh sh is there a filter ugh wait do you
have a filter on
i can't tell her to unmute can you hear
me
are you zooming dave what's like yeah
are you good at technology i'm not a cat
that is everything i'm sorry i can't
hear her oh you look like a fine
can you hear me okay it's the thought
that counts yeah we can hear
can you hear us we get it forget that
can you believe i mean that's so sweet
of him to do that i know
when was the last time you actually saw
it i feel the same way he does about
zoom
yeah um especially when my daughters
crash
[Music]
what do you think dear sit down
oh my
yeah i'm so grateful that you came here
let me tell you something
you know that uh little trick with the
computer and stuff that zoomer thing
that was my idea that was good you still
got it oh thank you
it was really effective i i really
thought i was like okay yeah you know
dave
i get it too um no are you you're
actually crying
oh that breaks my heart god bless you
i'm i'm so grateful that you are showing
up
well i i i can't i can't thank you
enough for everything and the friendship
that you demonstrated
for us when we were uh on the show and
it meant a great deal then
and this means a great deal as well
happy happy birthday and thank you
thank you for or did i invite myself i
don't know how this happened
you're this you're kind of the guest of
honor next to drew but wait wait
four years actually crying she's crying
she's shocked i told her she really
thought she might know i love
you i love you as well okay wait hold on
because we want to hear
everything we want to hear all of your
stories we have to take a break okay
we stick with us do i go back to the zoo
stay right here we're gonna have a lot
more with drew and dave
when we come back to the drew barrymore
[Applause]
[Music]
show
you know and so i just welcome back to
the drew barrymore show
this is so weird it's drew's birthday
i'm savannah guthrie i'm here to
celebrate drew
oh just david letterman swinging by to
shock drew
i don't think surprise is the word i
think it's shock i i know it's not my
show to produce but how great would this
be
if it was really a surprise for someone
guthrie
ladies and
in gentlemen i think we should uh roll a
certain clip
get off the furniture what is going on
would you like me to do a dance for you
okay
oh my god
[Music]
my goodness that happened
[Applause]
dave do you remember that anything about
that yeah i'll tell you honestly
uh i used to watch uh old movies uh
blackboard jungle
glenn ford and what happens is the
juvenile delinquent teenagers
take over the classroom and they're up
on glen ford's desk and they're gonna
beat him up
and so uh drew is there
and i love the high paul and then
and then she climbs up on the desk and i
i thought to myself oh no i've lost
control of the class
and and then my next thought was i think
i think i'm probably going to get kicked
and then everything changed you know
like in the wizard of oz when it goes
from black and white to color
that's what it was like i had no
plan of doing that it was
one of those moments in my life where i
felt like
a magnet was pulling me uh and it was
all very playful and well intended
and i just had no idea where it was
going and i
almost was like should i be embarrassed
did i do something bad
am i in trouble and i knew
in that moment that with one turn you
could have gone
why did you do that what's what's wrong
with you
and instead you had that smile
and you said to everyone this moment is
okay
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god
dave is right now and just let something
innocent and spontaneous be
innocent and spontaneous well i
recognized it immediately as being
unique it had it had
not happened prior to me has not
happened
since to me and later i was thinking
oh geez now what if she goes and does
this on leno's show
then i'll really be upset well with all
dudes
it was kind of a connection for us
throughout our
the rest of our existence here you
compelled me in a moment to
take a risk and you allowed it to be
paid off with kindness
and reciprocity and goodness and humor
which is my ultimate honestly i think
that's the greatest
award and reward that people can give
each other later we were of course
married yes we went to a church got
married look at me i'm like
i think you're so cute yeah i think i
did i i've had a crush on you forever
we were happy for another 20 minutes
yeah that's right and
like normal marriage drew was on your
show 20 times that's
20 times remarkable well again yes
absolutely and
and this is why um all credit to you
because
in the world of show business you have
you have two things you have show
business friendships which are
not really friendships and then you have
actual friendships and i considered
our relationship to be a true friendship
thank you i um i was not there
for shock value i was there to share a
moment with you
that took on a little bit of a life of
its own but my heart was so
well intended towards you now let's talk
about the the circumstance now
are you enjoying this part of your life
yeah
as hard and challenging as it is um
[Music]
i just feel like when i wake up in the
morning
i wake up to savannah and gail
i go to sleep to people like you and
you know i think of a jimmy fallon who's
like family
and you guys are who
jumpstart and close out our days and
that's why i felt so privileged to step
into a role that has been so
important to me as a citizen and a human
being walking around
you are literally telling people it's
okay to start their day here's how it's
going to go
here's some optimism here's some news
and for information and you would say
you got through the day i'm going to put
you to bed
congratulations right now you're allowed
to leave this is a great way for you to
look at it because
it's true the landscape uh in the early
morning
uh middle of the day or whenever we see
you
several other people have helped along
the way have been very beneficial oprah
was
fantastic so dave do you like being a
guest no
no i'm very uncomfortable about it
although i'm very pleased about the
zoomer thing and i
mentioned that was my idea it was a good
it worked yeah
uh no because i have nothing let me tell
you something do i can i talk
a lot of places don't want me to talk
out here
it's interesting about life you you
learn things
over that you already learned and then
you you forget because
you're drawn toward the mundane so you
you can't be sucked
into the the reality the drama and the
ugliness that
can be provided by life so you're drawn
toward the mundane
and you learn these lessons again and
again and because of the pandemic
you know people who have had it and
perhaps died
i know people who have died same same
with all of us
we're looking at a half a million people
i don't know how many wars
that is but a half a million stunning
that we're living with every day so i
think
uh humanity is temporary and we all know
that
and because it's temporary we need each
other
we more more than ever when you realize
it's temporary need each other
so i'm trying to be outgoing and
pleasant and helpful whenever i can
i always talk about both of your shows
as such like my training ground
my inspiration what i needed in life
when i would see you out in your trench
coat man in the field
i i love you both so much
i honestly live to make you proud
i mean that with all of my heart
i can't believe i get to call you guys
my friends
is she gonna be all right
we love you so much and you know what
drew i gotta say thank you for bringing
us together i never got to meet dave
letterman
savannah guthrie i said oh yeah i know
savannah and i realized no we never did
no but we're probably going to text all
the time now or zoom oh
yeah yeah you saw how much trouble i had
with the zoomer
dave thank you so much this was a great
way to kick up the party
this was awesome the love is just
getting started okay and we've got it
oh yeah we're just getting started but
we've got to have gifts because
what is a party without gifts so ross is
here
for our vffs who are also celebrating
their birthdays hi ross
well it's not just you celebrating
either right our vffs are all
celebrating their birthdays today and
guess what you're all getting some
gorgeous accessories from kendra spot
jewelry to bring home we need a
sparkle on a birthday like this the
zorte gold pinch cuff bangle as well as
the regina pearl
hoop earrings in gold a little bling for
your birthday and we're just getting
started drew
all right again dave thank you so much
for being here to celebrate our drew
we're gonna have more surprises right
after this
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back drew are you having a
good time at your birthday party
i don't know what i did to be this lucky
honestly i
i am i'm a person who never shuts up and
i'm totally speechless
well we're just getting started just the
idea of our next
surprise birthday guest had us at a
fever pitch most know him
as the host of the tonight show but you
know him drew better
bill who do you think it is it's jimmy
fallon
with a very special message for drew
when drew first interviewed me for her
show she asked who i was most starstruck
by
and i told the story about paul
mccartney you know
and you know it got me thinking about
meeting your idols you know there's
kind of three ways it can go one you
meet your favorite celebrity and
uh they're a monster and you go oh i
shouldn't have met my idol
two you meet your idol and they're
exactly what you want them to be and
actually you go this is amazing
which is like paul mccartney and then
third option is meet a celebrity
and that celebrity is drew barrymore and
she is so
stunning and warm and endearing
and and interested in you that you walk
away
thinking wow like wait drew barrymore
isn't just a celebrity i think
she's my best friend that's how i felt
when i
met drew for the first time i was on
saturday live drew was hosting
she was so creative and had a thousand
ideas
and was so giving and i remembered she
was going over two cards and someone was
trying to wig
and as i was having some other person
came over and said drew i just want to
show you i have a tattoo of
you on my leg and she was like that is
so
oh that's beautiful but this happened in
like 10 seconds
of so can you imagine someone's life
that happens to you and
and totally multitask cool as cucumber
just like
yeah oh yeah and just honestly just i'll
never forget it and
luckily i got to be friends with
uh drew for from that moment on
until now i'm very very lucky um
she's one in a zillion no matter who you
are she makes you feel like the most
important person in the room
i think jimmy said the smartest thing he
said drew is so
interested in you very much when you sit
down with someone
you feel like drew you only have eyes
for that person sitting across from you
and that's why you're good at this job
and that's why everybody loves you
welcome back everybody to drew's
birthday celebration we have another
surprise we're just we can't stop
and i have no idea what's happening no
you really really don't now i'm going to
give you some clues for our next guest
are you ready okay you first met over
coffee
she's been a real angel in cameroon life
and you may know her as poo poo yeah
it's cameron
cameron diaz
[Applause]
we speak english for the rest of us oh
that's how i talk i know that's how we
say hello and goodbye
and it lasts a long time can you know
what we're saying yeah
cameron of course you had to be here
because as long as i've known drew with
just a few years i've always known one
thing and that is that
cameron aka poo poo is her very very
very very closest friend what are some
of your favorite
birthday memories and drew memories
we have spent many birthdays together um
usually we have you know we get to
actually be together
usually we're together somehow we always
get together we're not big gift givers
we're more about experience so we always
try to
go someplace and do something uh with
the girls and be together
and cook and eat and hang and stay up
all night and just have the best time
she's still the only person who's uh
convinced me
well that convinced me she we like i
don't like co-sleeping
with anyone it's a thing i don't know
why but it's just my thing if it's like
a lover then
obviously that's different but no
friends no i will sleep in a bathtub
i'll sleep but i've slept on a pool
table like
you name it but but this one you spoon
with poo poo oh my gosh
yes and we've lived together for periods
of time
and um been roommates and i've slept in
a tent
while like my fever was breaking on a
chilean mountain in a thunderstorm and
like patagonia
yeah i mean we've been everywhere
together can you guys
please explain the nicknames because you
have i've
so i mean can you i think that's a real
question
well it started out as like classic boy
humor
and then it just evolved into a true
term of endearment
and then it just stuck when we're at a
restaurant
she'll you know say to the waiter ask
poopoo what she wants and people
now charlie's angels of course is
everyone's favorite movie
i saw that the sex and the city ladies
are getting back together it did make me
think
could there be a charlie's angel reunion
would you guys
ever i'm getting an amen from the crowd
here
i'm glad that people feel that way you
know
i'll be grannies and inner tubes with
poopoo
so you know that we can do anything and
everything as long as we're together
i have a whole life to live with you i
always say never say never
and i feel the same way there's never a
time where we're not going to
be connected or you know consider
something together i can't wait to just
grow old with you
and to experience the rest of our life
together because
it's truly one of the great joys of my
life is our friendship
and when i think about you like
literally i'll cry because
i just think you're so special and to
celebrate you
is the absolute like
every year it's one of my favorite times
of the year is to get to celebrate you
you've made me a better person my whole
life and you've seen me through
everything ugly beautiful lost
life and universe getting
your bed is like literally i just didn't
want to sleep on the floor all night
holding your hand
from the ground i know because that was
a bad breakup and you
you and and yet every breakup was okay
because we were always there and i can't
wait to grow old with you too
because we're gonna be old together i
know it's charlie's grannies yeah we
just came up with the concept
you know she actually sent something for
you we're in your kitchen
if it's in your fridge over here a
little well you'll see
something i hope it's her wine aveline
is it aveline it's avalyn
by the way allow me to use this moment
to
talk about cameron's amazing wine line
but poop cut that part out because you
don't need to talk about my wine this is
just to toast you
excuse me that's my sister you're
talking about and i'm really proud
because also you're trying to put
something out there that's better for
people
and everybody loves it a toast to you
drew i love you santa i love you poohpa
it's delicious by the way cameron send
me a case i love it okay ross
[Applause]
hook a brother up too cool yes exactly
it's gift time right yeah gift time and
you guys are gonna flip out about this
one it's the flower tool
our hair tools titanium rotating iron
this colorful hot tool is both beautiful
and functional
the full collection of hair tools can be
found exclusively in walmart stores
and on walmart.com and our bffs are
getting it happy birthday
back to you all right we are gonna be
right back but
there are two very special guests who
couldn't be here today
but they had a really good excuse
get the tissues out they were at school
take a look at the little cartoon
that your daughters frankie and olive
put together
oh no hi mom
olive and i wanted to stretch to send
you a special message on your birthday
so here it goes
we love you more than squirrels and
poles
we're eating cheese in the boys
we love you more than holding hands
or swinging on the track eats
we love you so much it makes us nuts
we love you so much with all our guts
there's really one thing left to say
you're the best
mom in the world happy birthday
[Music]
i
welcome back it's time for drew's news
and by the way i have no idea what i'm
saying because what's in the prompter is
a surprise
i don't even know the headlines that's
right that's why it's so fun
you put the drew in drew's news and
today it's all about you
you've been making headlines your whole
life from big newspaper profiles to rave
reviews
to even your advice for new year's
resolutions back in 1983.
you told people not to smoke not to
drink and to avoid
salt you also told them they should go
see e.t because quote that's good for
you
well e.t is still one of the biggest
movies of all time and you're still one
of our most beloved
stars let's take a look at a clip from
entertainment tonight
of you talking about making this iconic
film
i could act like myself the whole time
on that shoot because gertie sword was
like me
sometimes i cry and she does sometimes
cry
and it's a story about a whole family
and i love doing that movie
when you were in et or and even
afterwards a lot of what you talked
about is how crazy you were about steven
spielberg are you still such good
friends
yes we love each other i go over to his
house and
we we play games and we see each other a
lot and we're still
best friends yeah he um
yeah he's like the first person i knew
cared
he does care can you venture a guess
about who is about to join us right now
first person that cared about me yeah
please welcome the man behind countless
blockbusters
oscar golden globe and emmy
award-winning director who needs
no introduction steven spielberg
oh drew face i still care about you i've
always cared about you
ever since that first time this little
blonde hurricane
walked into an audition in my office
and took uh us by storm and then soon
took the entire world by storm that was
you then
and that is you today you know i think
one of the people that mean the most to
me
to be accountable
and a good person and have my you know
what together
it's definitely you i always thought
every time i was doing something good or
right
um i would always think about you know
how
you would think and feel about it
because i loved making you proud i
live to make you proud oh
thank you and you've made me so proud so
consistently for
for i don't want to say so many decades
but come on let's face it it's been so
many decades
it's um it's going to be 41 it's 40
years
it's 40 years her et interview was the
best
because when she walked into the office
she didn't want to talk about the movie
she didn't even
care what the film was about she wanted
to talk to me about her
punk band she was forming people eaters
none of it really existed but so so
we put a song in et purple people
leaders just in order
to please drew to to make that story
kind of have a full circle
tell me if this is right you guys that
it was actually drew at six years old
who came up with the line when she sees
e.t for the first time and she says i
don't like his feet
yeah she said that during rehearsal and
i said i said oh
drew can you remember to say that when
the cameras were rolling and she said
okay
and when we roll the cameras that was
the first thing she said you came up
with a lot of lines in the movie that
melissa matheson
had not come up with and there's the
famous story and i think we have a
follow-up today courtesy of stephen that
when drew posed for playboy
he sent you a quilt and it said cover up
yup because that's what parents do and
stephen then what happened
well then i sent her the playboy layout
and i had somebody from an artist come
over and do paper doll cut out clothes
which i
glued onto all of the partially exposed
photographs and sent the whole thing
back to drew
now she's dressed yes and
and then about a week later drew
sent me something and i don't know if
you have it there but she sent me
an apology that was my response to the
playboy
it's being covered up yep yep and those
are still
like in one of your rooms in your house
yes
oh my god there it is
what she said on the picture was she
said the first one was
i'm sorry the second one was i've seen
the light
and the last thing frame is um
i'm on i'm on my way
you always uh just inspired me to be my
best
and then you held both of
my girls my olive and my frankie you
know all of right when she was born
she was so little and she fell asleep on
your chest
remember and i remember i just i love
you and you've
had an incredible family you know i was
like a first
young person in your life you were you
you were my training wheels for
fatherhood group
i'm so glad because um
there's no way i'd be sitting here
without you
ever i love you so much and thank you
and thank you and let me just say one
thing
uh uh just a little more fatherly advice
but maybe more producerial advice
i want you to direct more i loved whip
it so much
as you know you came to my office and
you sat in the screening room
and you showed me a rough cut of your
film for the first time and then i loved
um
i loved our deal you know you know best
coast
uh the music video you made in 2000 and
i think it was nine or 2011
and i just think you're a gifted
director and i want to see you do that
more
i love you so much you make you continue
to make me so proud and i love you too
drew happy birthday
thank you steven thank you for my life
all right we are back in a moment with
more surprises and more
drew's news right after this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey drew it's called your favorite chef
wishing you a very happy birthday
from gordon and oscar lots of love
moly only it's your birthday
happy birthday drew peach and i love you
so much
we're your biggest fans and we just want
to say
happy birthday drew you
isn't that right you've been a huge
inspiration
and just a light in my life and i'm so
happy to see you
thriving and killing it and talking to
all my friends on your show
happy birthday drew you
[Music]
[Applause]
hey i love you welcome back to drew's
news this is your show
well savannah it says here that you've
got a news story for us
i sure do drew it's a big one too
there's a huge
mystery it's been absolutely stumping
experts
for decades and we decided it was time
to do
a little digging of our own so we got
dateline's keith morrison
on the case oh my gosh and he filed this
report in today's
drew crime oh my gosh we've been talking
about it take a look if he would ever do
something with us
hello and welcome to drew crime
mysteries
a true crime series dedicated to
mysteries surrounding people
named drew i'm keith morrison
people who know her say that drew
barrymore can
light up a room in fact she lights up
her room so much
it's a little suspicious drew
is too nice i mean who is that nice it
just like it started to concern me
she spends entire segments of her show
helping people with stain removal that's
not normal
she also doesn't age your skin is like
like a baby's butt yeah like a baby's
booty yeah it's just so hard to believe
someone like her really exists
and that's when we started to think what
if she doesn't
what if drew barrymore isn't real what
if drew barrymore doesn't exist
i mean i was married to her i don't even
know if she exists
yes her friends feared the worst
but drew barrymore did exist
or did she we started wondering like
maybe she's some type of hologram
or like collective hallucination
maybe she's just a bunch of kittens
in a human suit i mean has anybody
thought about that
[Music]
yes drew barrymore seemed a little too
good to be true
so we obtained a little bit of drew
barrymore's dna
and what did we discover why it was
shocking
it confirmed not only does drew
barrymore exists
she's one of a kind
that's it for this edition of true crime
mysteries
thank you for joining us
[Music]
joining us now is the man who finally
after decades cracked the case
keith morrison no oh man that was
that was such a tough one too the people
we had to talk to the dirt we had to dig
i cannot believe it hello drew happy
birthday thank you
and i have all the things that could
have been said about me this was so tame
and kind
well hmm we left some of those things in
the cutting room before
understandably so keith was this one of
the
sweetest and most adorable mysteries
you've ever had to solve
undoubtedly the sweetest and most
adorable mystery
keith thank you so much for making
drew's day special
it's so fun to have you here and i am
happy
i'm just i'm delighted to be here i'm
still pinching myself and happy birthday
drew
thank you so much thank you and we are
back right after this
well ross put on his party outfit for
this last segment i would like visit
thank you for noticing this is my third
change for you this barrymore all right
it's your birthday you deserve it
i clocked every sweater you were wearing
thank you
this is definitely my favorite outfit i
agree so you
i look great thank you for noticing all
right and i'm doing drew you're going to
freak out over this uh this next gift
right because our girl drew you know we
know her she loves organizing
baskets and shelf liners she's a real
party animal
matching little bowls for everything on
her desk and her happy place is where
not not marie oh god sorry marie condo
is my happy place yeah and
and she's doing a collab with the
container store which we dorked out
over on drew's news oh yeah you love the
container store and guess what vff's
you are all getting a 150 credit
okay we still have one more gift this
one is for you though drew
i want to say hello to our final
surprise live
from city hall please welcome the mayor
of west hollywood california
lindsay hi miss madam mayor how are you
i am great it's an honor and a pleasure
to be here with you today to celebrate
the one and only drew barrymore she grew
up here this is her hometown we know
this is
uh a place where she we hold her dear in
our hearts and
um west hollywood is just so so proud of
the success
that drew has had and while many people
know us for fabulous gay men
i myself am partial to powerhouse women
and mayor horvath i know there's a
special reason you wanted to be here
for drew's birthday and a special gift
for her can you tell us
yes so we have a very uh official uh
proclamation
to make today here in the city of west
hollywood um allow me to read
whereas drew barrymore who grew up on
north poinsetti a place in west
hollywood
is recognized as a celebrated actress
producer director talk show host
and entrepreneur and whereas ms
barrymore has a special connection to
the city of west hollywood
now therefore be it resolved that the
city council of the city of west
hollywood declared
february 22nd 2021
drew barrymore day in west hollywood
[Applause]
hello
thank you i i just officially had a
heart attack
all right having your own day is is
great but there's even more
mayor horvath what else do you have for
drew oh my god today we would like to
bestow
upon you ms barrymore a key to the city
of west hollywood
thank you for being such a wonderful
ambassador of our community
[Applause]
it really does feel wizard of odds thank
you very much
i'm very grateful i i loved growing up
in west hollywood
it was such an interesting community to
grow up in
it was really open-minded and
open-hearted and it set me up for
success in life to accept people and
care about them
and love them for who they were
and we love you back thank you so much
thank you
i really appreciate it
[Applause]
this is this feels like a little dorothy
in the wizard of oz it's beautiful
click your heels but it's all true
everyone loves you ross
what we forgot the cake we roll out the
cake
without a cake come on
oh it's a pretty one thank you it's so
beautiful
drew you are loved you are loved happy
birthday
and this is your show so you have to say
goodbye d
nice i can't believe you are here what
you did
for all of us when you started club
quarantine
made us feel like everything was gonna
be okay when we were the most scared
so thank you we love you drew i hope you
just are soaking it in
i hope you absorb it and when you lay
your head down in bed tonight i hope all
these memories come rushing back and you
just
really feel it because it's your
birthday every day is drew barrymore day
definitely the best day of my life and
i really just want to say thank you to
chris and ember and jason and marianne
and robin and leah mr daniel and
everyone
i do that show with like literally i
wish i could be cooler and keep it
together but i can't
[Applause]
i don't know how i will ever
pay this back but i will live my life
paying it forward
thanks you guys
[Music]
you